hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the Kabuki
ethics book 10 Aristotle is going to
tell us that some pleasures are in fact
banned pleasures for us and other
pleasures are good pleasures now how is
he going to get to that point
particularly given the fact that he has
at numerous points said that pleasure
itself is something good how can there
then be bad pleasures there are some
ways to approach this and Aristotle is
not going to take one way that I just
want to lay out because otherwise people
might think that he'd forgotten about
this or he's not you know taking this
into consideration hedonist philosophers
that his philosophers who think that the
good the fundamental but just it is
pleasure and the fundamental evil pain
will often say the way that we can
declare some pleasures to be bad that
for us it is that we see that they will
preclude of other pleasures are not
compatible with other greater pleasures
or they can bring about pain along with
that and so they're kind of mixed and
and the balance of pleasure over pain is
not particularly positive Aristotle does
not take that line of
instead he begins from pointing out the
fact that pleasures do differ from each
other in he's going to think about this
in terms of pleasures as being connected
with and coming out of and in a certain
sense perfecting activities rather than
just merely being stimulus response that
we get from having certain senses or you
know other faculty is stimulated so when
Aristotle is going to tell us that some
pleasures are better in some ways than
others he says that pleasures differ in
kind from each other that's the term
that we're using there in kind sometimes
it's translated in quality is a dose and
a dose means something like species or
kind or its height so some pleasures you
know we do think are better than others
and that's why we pursue them more
ardently or more consistently than
others yeah and this may vary from
person to person but you can take this
general idea that they don't think that
all pleasures are equal I mean if you
want certain evidence of this in a very
commonsensical
way go into any store or any restaurant
where there are choices for a person and
see whether that person is able to
actually make a choice by make a choice
I don't mean putting your finger you
know at random on some spot saying I'll
have that entree or walking down a lot
of CDs in places that still sell CDs and
just picking one out I mean say I want
this rather than all the other
alternatives or opportunities that are
available to me the fact that people can
it is a sign that I must have some other
weird of the factor intervening like you
know people saying I'm this nationality
so I must eat this kind of food or you
know I have a religious obligation to
eat this this particular dish of this
day or something like that it's a sign
that people do in fact think that
pleasures vary in not
I by Barry and what we could say valued
somewhere some are better than others so
Aristotle talks about this in terms of
activities he says that activities have
different modes of perfection there's
different ways in which the activity is
brought to its performance and when
we're talking about perfection of the
activity we mean something like sight
the the activity of seeing seeing its
object like you're seeing me right now
we're hearing hearing what's being said
mind understanding what's being said or
the significance of what's on before
thinking about things so various
activities various faculties have
different modes of perfection and
pleasure as he's told us earlier we have
another video specifically about this
comes out of the perfection of the
activity he actually says perfection
purpose plated pleasure perfects the
activity and how does it do so it does
so in a way that's different than the
object of say of sight or the the the
faculty itself the ability to see or
perhaps the organs that we used for that
and it does so differently than say a
ham it would you know say a virtue or or
something else like that what does it
mean for it to perfected Aristotle says
that it sort of brings it to a
fulfillment it is as I've said before
sort of the icing on the cake that makes
the cake also much better that brings
the cake to a conclusion makes it into a
whole so we have these different modes
of activity and each has its own
perfection each has its own pleasures
and Arizona will say that the pleasures
of the intellect differ from those of
the senses and the pleasures of the
senses differ from each other so the
pleasure that you take in tasting is not
the same pleasure as you take
in hearing or in understanding so
Aristotle actually said that says that
some senses are better than others this
is what he says in The Naked McCain
ethics he said talks about this in other
places as well so sight excels touched
in purity and hearing and smell Excel
taste so sight is really the best one
all together and then there's there's
hearing and smell the taste and touch
are kind of at the lower end
Aristotle this is very typical I think
of a Greek ancient Greek way of looking
at things
although not everybody because you know
the many are the ones who are
particularly interested in touch and
taste right but the cultivated are
interested in sight and hearing and to a
lesser extent smell in any case we could
disagree about you know we're these
these tastes and smells ought to fit in
with each other there's a little love
snake that the senses differ from each
other the pleasures differ from each
other and therefore they are going to
you know some are going to be better and
some are going to be worse we can also
talk about activities different from
each other in what we might say strictly
moral values some activities are
appropriate and some activities are
inappropriate some activities are going
even further are considered to be Noble
or beautiful other activities are
considered to be ugly or shameful and a
person might in fact derive pleasure
from something that is shameful but that
shamefulness is going to contaminate
that pleasure to a certain extent so
Aristotle thinks that you know pleasures
of good and Noble activities are in fact
good pleasures those are the things that
we want to choose those are the things
that we want to take into consideration
and our moral deliberation and our our
actions and our choices and the
pleasures that are associated with bad
or base activities are themselves bad
now insofar as they are a pleasure per
se they are good but that play
is coming from something bad so it's
sort of tainted or contaminated by the
badness the the pleasure itself is
pleasant but shameful so you know what
would be examples of this in our own
society
you know gluttonous overeating would be
an example of that Lester so in some
other societies where other things may
be considered to be very very shameful
pleasures you think about you know the
effect of the sexual revolution and the
proliferation of images of the human
body and sexual activity through the
internet and sort of the loosening and
laxness of moral standards about those
matters today in comparison to say fifty
years ago and I don't mean you know
necessarily about any individual person
but about the society and there are some
pleasures that people certainly do find
pleasant but but are considered to be
shameful we still have some things that
are considered shameful in that register
as well and so you know you can do all
sorts of things taking drugs you know be
taking things that are very pleasurable
intensely pleasurable but often quite
addictive and illegal and you know
ruinous in many respects to not only
moral life but even being able to do
things like hold down a job depending on
what kind of drug we're talking about
and pull Aristotle would go so far as to
call that a bad pleasure so it is
possible for us to distinguish between
these now they're people who are going
to bring up a certain relativity is it
well wait a second aren't these
standards rather arbitrary Aristotle
grapples with this this issue by saying
that we hold in all cases the thing
really is what it appears to be through
the good person the food aisles so
diagnosis could mean the virtuous person
the prudent person the firown' Emil's
it can also mean the person who is self
controlled who
understands what the good is doesn't
necessarily want to do it but it does
make himself do it and is able to
recognize what is genuinely good what is
genuinely bad and also what is genuinely
pleasant and genuinely painful so the
the good person is the measure for what
is genuinely pleasurable like you says
since uh the good person qua good is the
standard so the things that hasn't
seemed to him or her to be pleasures are
pleasures and the things he enjoys
aren't Pleasant he says nor should it
doesn't cost it cost surprised that
things disagreeable to the good person
should seem pleasant to some people why
mankind is liable to many corruptions
and diseases and the things in question
are not really pleasant but only
pleasant to those particular persons who
are in a condition to think themselves
I suspect Aristotle would probably look
at smoking tobacco like that you know
when you first have a cigarette it's in
certain respects a pleasant experience
you know there's the smell of the
tobacco there's a weird sensation of
your lungs almost collapsing in on
themselves yeah there's the rush that
the native team gives yeah but you know
and it really is an acquired experience
it takes going through it at least by my
experience quite a few cigarettes before
it becomes something that you you view
as normal for you and as as pleasant it
might be that you actually enjoy hanging
out with other people who are smoking
and that might be where the pleasure
lies and there's a lot of things like
them so some of these are perhaps not
good pleasures according to Aristotle he
also suggests that there are some
pleasures that are distinctively human
pleasures there are a lot of pleasures
that we share in common with the other
animals at least the animals that have
similar abilities for sensation like we
do some of them may be pleasures of
sight you know looking at certain things
many of them are pleasures of touch or
pleasures of taste and they don't really
share with us as far as we can tell
although animal behavior may prove this
entirely wrong they don't share with us
the pleasures of thoughts the pleasures
of using our intellects to say solve
mathematical problems for those who
actually enjoy doing that sort of stuff
learning languages I don't necessarily
even know that they share the same sort
of pleasure of travel that we do
although again animal behaviorists might
provide us with new information about
this about the rationality of at least
certain animals so ears level suggests
that the best pleasures are the ones
that are distinctively
human because they are higher they use
the higher parts of our soul the higher
faculties and probably involve the
intellectual virtues